oh let's go we need one more to get this
tournament kicked off the bullet zone
one average rating is now 2029
we are live it's gonna be game on there
is a minimum now Matt 20 players at
least have entered here we go
coming up 20 seconds oh man a lot of
strong players a lot of big dogs here
who is gonna win okay here we go
coming up three two one
tournament starting let's do this
please I want to be the one that gives
out beatings they don't give me a
beating here are they gonna start this
or what says starting here we go okay
let's not okay let's go let's go let's
go to chop that guy get the Queen real
quick come on give me the Queen okay
okay no the diagonal is weak in the
seventh rank is weak and I'm getting a
pond maybe getting a pond they're gonna
take this dark squares dark squares move
right here 39 seconds
now what take here repair my pawn
structure hit this pawn takes and then
takes I'm hitting this pawn again let's
take this that's free isn't it I'm on
that there we go
smooth smooth sailing from here trade
rook c8 I want this file to I'm greedy
gotta be greedy let's take this and then
pin and then I'm on this
and then I kick this bishop around and
I'm gonna keep going with that push and
then give a check and then keep this
pawn a tap-in and save that guy I think
he's important let's hit this [ __ ] up a
little bit and now that and then let's
get these bishops off quickly you need
to get quick wins here
let's check keep pushing keep pushing
here push and then push again
I don't want that Bishop to get this pun
there we go
I had a meetin - coming up mean - back
to tournament they forfeited on time -
two - a bunch of two's for first oh man
okay let's try this okay it's not the
first time it transposes quickly into
the caro-kann it's guard that it's gonna
be piled up on oh oh that was almost a
bad mouse slip oh I can't allow these
mouse lips get this h-file rook to be
okay things are good here
things are very good dark squares dark
squares let's give a check what do they
do now their King has to go elsewhere
let's hit this night oh I got it
no I don't I don't want to take that
night yeah let's go here I didn't want
to put you guys think a three there was
something of c-5 right there let's get
this in before it's too late and I'm
already capture with my queen otherwise
there's a fork and let's come back here
I want to get Bishop here I want to
control this diagonal oh oh okay let's
do this oh I'm in a fork crap let's come
back here there's got to be something
maybe against this diagonal let's get
this open please open up
oh I'm on the Queen Mother Brooke me
please
let's watch this let's watch over that
my king is tucked in oh oh they only
have ten seconds
they must be scared they're scared Queen
trade we trade I could burn their time
no let's not do that and I don't know
what I'm doing with that move
run King back to tournament I got that
one I couldn't even talk oh yeah they
need water I need water and I need to
move quick throw my puns get developed
okay this is a repeat of the is it am I
playing gets the same guy okay let's do
that okay and I might need to come all
the way back we'll see about that though
now a shoe bag there's Queen takes a but
you kind of run into trouble if you do
that I want the night to go here if it
goes to have six they're crazy let's do
this and I could take the night but I
like my bishops position boxing out this
night here Queen c2 coming up could be
pretty good although Bishop here could
be annoying let's see I might want to
back my bishop up Oh
do I have something yes okay no I don't
I don't I miss I messed up what did I
mean to really do oh man okay let's try
this darn it
okay trap that guy I want to get this
night okay I could win this stuff remain
calm
you've been through worse remain calm
you've been through worse and you can't
move ponds that are Bend what's the
matter with you f-for coming up here we
go uh-oh the night has to go their
tricks I got them take that rook and
I'll take the knight if Bishop they're
more tricks okay let's come back here
just for a second
just for a second I want to get written
I get witih I want to get rid of that
tricky Knight the tricky Knights need to
leave okay
ah there we go
primo primo primo primo go go go go go
and push my pond
okay back to tournament 12 twelve eleven
medicine for goat is up there okay who's
this I don't know 2048 French defence
yes it is I should have played Bishop d7
okay here we go I get this pond I'm
gonna take it Bishop d7 is important
fees to have there here we go
mmm let's do this choose that clean away
a little bit I don't know what I want to
do okay let's come here
and there I have something I'm on the
knight twice Aaron other night in the
bishop I'm not on the knight twice I
lied pawn takes Bishop are they gonna
resign I'm getting material the Queen is
protected got the knight now you got the
H pun Queens are off it's looking good
definitely looking good back to
tournament that was a quick win 2012 11
2012 11 i'm the breed here we go 46
seconds more Primos if the knight takes
I couldn't do that move okay and aged
six I'll take the knight I want to get
c4 in c4 I'm okay with doubled pawns I'm
threatening to take this pawn now they
might miss it they might miss Bishop
takes H they missed it because there's a
pin if they capture it when I take the
Queen if not I'm gonna come back to d3
move the king no I got the Queen look up
create it all up in the file h3 queen to
f5 guard f3 I'm bond both nights here
comes h6 killer move I'm on the knight
resignation rook g1 back to tournament a
quick win 30 2019 10 21 minutes left
this guy's giving me many beatings I'm
pretty sure mmm alright let's come back
and let's see what they do in response
to that let's push here let's take and
then do this
and then let's do this see what they it
was what they do okay okay I think I
have no no no no no oh wait let's see
what they do with that they're giving me
the light square bishop really really
why would they do something like that oh
well it is bullet isn't it that's a
reason I want to keep this dark square
bishop around and I don't want to castle
okay no no no I have I have a plan here
I have a plan and involves kicking the
pieces around Alera hit these rooks a
little bit let's come here and then do
what next okay he comes the bishop it's
winning material there we go okay now I
need to get over here let's do this
okay I'm in trouble definitely in
trouble here ah man why did I let this
happen
Oh bishop their killer that's a killer
I'm crunched right here
I'm definitely crunched ah man look at
this this is awful I got nothing
something Bad's happening and oh I'm
down on time that's the other thing
that's happening oh man that one's
painful now this guy who's this guy um
ah man I thought I was doing so good I
liked that position I really did like
that position getting a f4o dark-squared
bishop s' as soon as the dark square
bishop scum off the game ends really
quick game ends really quick you got to
get rid of this Knight okay dark square
Bishop queenside castle let's do this
just stop Knight f5 its Castle first and
then do this and then just push my age
pot down right open up the age file and
it's a win
you could take here or here it doesn't
matter I think I have everything covered
[Music]
there's no defense is there Queen g7 or
here combination the two difficult to
defend actually this right here there's
not really much defense rook up
I take mate
okay back to tournament forty forty two
forty medicine for goat medicine for
goat is up there where's the guy that
beat me why isn't he up there was he
just a little long ways off or what
let's go with this whoa
given me this 'if I've Square and I
should probably be watching okay my
knight wants to get to e5 and when it's
there let's make sure I get that in my
Knight wants to get to e5 very quickly
very very quickly just in the nick of
time hitting everything and defending
and defending an important detail now I
Castle Bishop d7 stops Knight here okay
let's get out of there get him out of
there first my knight controls this
position I'm looking for rook b8 b5 King
up is probably a good move there is
possibilities for just uh this type of
an imbalance however let's get this in
first chase this night away a little bit
make sure my rooks will have a target if
I'm gonna go in for that imbalance and
we're about even with the time I'm
looking to push and then Bishop to b5
which is winning material here we go
here we go it's not the winner material
but if I get that Knight out of there
there's very little hope let's work with
this next and the next one is this is my
knight is fantastic right here it's open
this up get to see three and a three and
there's tactics my rook on g3 is even
good let's watch over this let's watch
over this my knight has that covered and
now here comes
it comes rook here and what else have
everything look up look at my night king
and queen they're perfect right there so
next up let's get this going
probably rook here I'm functioning all
on dark squares all on dark squares my
Knights pin there's rook takes pawn
right now okay I'm okay with this
exchange sac
I've got Knight here maybe let's secure
this and I'm looking for mates mates
coming up I have a okay time down on
time they are fifty four forty I jumped
ahead I think medicine forgot lost oh
I'm playing against them
here we go can I get a quick kill let's
protect this and that and okay here we
go
f4 Knight f3 Knight f2 castle f5 or play
on this wing as well let's hit this pond
see what they do and also be for opening
the position up let me capture their I
don't want that pond to get any further
down let's open this up to the a file
Bishop to c4 oh I got to watch over g3
g3 I definitely need to watch over that
and this has to be good ok I'm getting
up that dark square pond next or am i
okay we're gonna see we're gonna see I
gotta take that and then come back oh
and watch over this their mates
there's probably mates oh I think there
was rip take spawn there let's get in
here and let's do this
and then that how much time we're about
even with time let's get over here and
push this pond it's past still past
and let's get this in I'm on d4 at the
end of all this my bishop is fantastic
my bishop is definitely fantastic that
comes with check and let's do this too
why did I do that look over here on b4
I'm dropping that give check I don't
know not there there's an e2 issue on e
- there I don't have any time
oh did I win I won a point six seconds
oh man oh man sorry if I'm getting loud
okay I couldn't think would just stare
it like me pre moving oh man okay what
an eternity it is to have let me tell
you what an eternity it is to have like
two minutes or 51 seconds this is so
much time rook to c8 and open things up
maybe let's go check in there and let's
get this in what am i doing let's come
over here my queen needs to get back on
these dark squares oh seventh-ranked I'm
dead okay oh this is a wonderful square
for my knight and I have the H file now
there's gonna be made on each seven may
be made on h7 they might miss it no
they're not missing it where does my
bishop wanna be right here I'm being
sneaky maybe and then right here and
then push mmm hang on hang on
well it's oh they're taking that aren't
they do I have to really guard stuff
it's come here they're down on time
mm-hmm what do I do
let's go check in and then play here
1514 gonna take my knight come on go go
go go go let's get that bishop out of
there I don't want to work myself into a
pin no why do they have to do that yes
give me that night hit the rook
oh they're following in time pressure I
got this let's go check in in another
one let's take that pun
move move move okay back to tournament
88 88 70 54 52 these are this is a very
difficult one to win a lot of people
could come back very easily 88 70-54
come on pair me up I need to get double
use here myself and this guy are the
only ones that have ten games in let's
go ten minutes Wow come on pair me up
Arnaud is something wrong with it
uh-oh is something wrong with chess cube
again don't tell me okay here we go
double the points main line mainlining
h4 oh they dropped that bish a quick
resign come on
yes back to tournament 108 108 88 that
guy just actually was probably ahead
just for a split second more c5 okay
let's go with this again last time I had
a great grip on that a 5 square and we
might be getting to see that again
maybe I got to stop Knight b5 first and
get Queen to e7 in then Knight d7 but
let's stop that first I don't want that
I'm okay with this pin eventually I'll
get myself out of it eventually let's
get this in castle and then tuck my
queen back and then get my Knight to g4
and then e 5 and I think everything is
good I may want to play rook to be first
but no this is this is better ok so just
gonna have to deal with this
there's cool there's ripping our queen
check ok I have to deal with it and keep
my onion do I keep my rook around here
let's throw this check in if the bishop
locks are got h4 otherwise Bishop g4 is
strong too
okay I got this Bishop g4 Knight to g4
as well it could be pretty strong with
my bishop also coming to deed
that's got to be a killer actually okay
let's do this now the night is stranded
it's in a good it seems like it's in a
good position but it's really not it's
really not this this must be pretty good
right here there's got to be something
to this right here with the Bishop to d4
or not maybe they'll fall for it
take that however you want bishop d4
there it is killer there's four pieces
on this diagonal I'm going to take the
most popular one or maybe I'm not wait I
thought I was getting the Queen but this
is still working I got the rook at least
oh I'm still getting everything I'm
getting the Queen and the knight
interesting interesting sequence of
moves right there let's grab this and
then take that pawn in a couple turns my
fish is probably gonna get shut down
let's pivot here because I could and
then look for the e3 Square there down
on time back to tournament 128 86 8 128
86 68 that's a pretty significant lead
but maybe that guy is ready to win her
actually it seemed like he got in
another game and maybe he ended up
losing okay I need to get castled Queen
side I have to guard that square now e3
next oh okay I have time to do this
get my night out night out and then get
my rook back over here and get my king
up in my Bishop back I need to get some
trades but let's throw this in first
look back capture if they do that why
would they do that okay let's get this
in and then oh why did I give that up
there's Knight check Oh am I missing
another fork let's grab one of these
pawns at least my bishop is on that
let's get this pawn this is where maybe
the the bishop could show itself is a
very long range piece and now my king is
going to be going into pac-man mode
gobble up a bee and then run my a pond
am I missing anything as long as I don't
hang a piece I think I'm our
okay let's grab this and come back the
night is no match for the bishop in this
position absolutely no match two
connected past pawns are also very
valuable and let's kick this night away
those pawns are not fast enough
okay
let's give a check let's give a check
mate mate
me there we go back to tournament 146
106 106 five minutes left all right
I need a couple more wins if I get a
couple more wins if these next two games
are wins I think unless somebody gets a
bunch of quick resigner zai got it let's
go I got the big bad wolf here right now
playing against the big bad wolf here
okay let's go let's go it's more more of
this get the Queen
give me the Queen rook c8 that Knight
can move at any moment or my bishop
could be hit Oh what am i doing
easy there let's get out of that okay I
have to castle artificially okay time to
regroup here time to regroup oh this is
gonna be bad okay they're gonna take
this but hopefully I could get castled
and it's a good thing I'm watching over
this square otherwise that's a killer
isn't it okay and let's
I'm in trouble I'm in big trouble okay I
got to do this this is a killer ah man I
need my knight around
I need my knight around man this is not
good let's do this
I need to keep my rook on the board how
pitiful was that that was really really
bad please give me tricks I'm looking
for tricks here please let my rook get
active come on you know you want to let
my wreck active let me get active rook
here rook takes Bishop was available for
a bunch oh wait a second could I
actually come back from this what are
they doing it's just time I have to burn
their time and I think I got it hang on
push
eventually that - give that out mm-hmm
what am i doing
ten seconds to kick the King around a
little bit
it's actually equal material it's good
over here and then there and now I want
to get in position where I could give
checks oh that wasn't it I'm gonna oh
it's my turn I lost track Oh back to
tournament I lost track three minutes
left I thought it was my opponent's move
that was that's why I wasn't moving ah
who's this snoop I got a play against
Snoop right now 18:18 Dennis
ah man and that by the way is not the
first time I've done that I was just
staring at the clock thinking it was my
opponent's move oh man
let's go snoop 2 minutes 34 seconds if
that guy wins
oh he's 20 oh it's my turn okay let's
focus on this game let's focus on this
game here
I want to get efore in so I need to shut
down that Bishop first build my Center I
already have an advantage I'm looking
for a five also Queen d2 wouldn't induce
some more weaknesses let's back up first
so my queen isn't overloaded for when I
take there and let's get to the c6
square I want to get the dark square
Bishop off the board as well dark square
bishop I'm gonna take my knight I'm
going to take on g6 I'm like in the g6
here we go let's take this check out h6
and then right here next oh I should
have just played 94 this was this was
better check check and then mate come on
move yes back to tournament 166 146 is
that guy gonna win out on tiebreaks one
minute thirty one minute thirty uh-oh is
this the guy that's in the lead oh this
is the guy that's in the lead if I'm
losing I have to check to see how much
time as I might have to UM now let this
game finish I gotta use all the tactics
available to me all the tactics come on
you're gonna break down my center that
push is probably good come on let's go
let's go here mate
looking for me what's this boom I'm
gonna take that one 18650 seconds left
oh man they they crumbled under the
pressure they crumbled under pressure
that's it that seals it there's no way
you could come back from that 50 seconds
okay this is the guy I got to get back
he gave me a beating the first time we
played I got to try and give a beating
back could it happen could it happen oh
I know how it feels to have a mouse slip
yep and I want to stop the knight from
coming to d4 and then I'm gonna target
this pun and everything's gonna be quite
all right
everything's oh I shouldn't have dropped
that
uh-oh I'm gonna give him this okay
things turn so quickly
let's get B for in what is that Bishop
doing oh they're just playing with me
right here they're just being silly
haha they're gonna let their clock tick
I know I know these tricks I know what
you're up to
yep they're like yeah go ahead there it
is they knew what was going on first I'm
gonna take it there it is hmm close out
of that good games oh wow
not without a couple losses though